[Music]
hey I'm Diamond I hope everyone's you
know feeling the AGI today um I'll be
sharing our AI agents at data dog and
what we've learned building the devops
engineer who never sleeps I came all the
way from the New York Times building uh
right across here uh to see all of you
so I hope it's worth
it I've been working for my entire
career about 15 years or so in AI trying
to build more AI friends and co-workers
um I wouldn't read too much into that I
have human ones too um I promise um
throughout the kind of AI Winters and
lws of the last 15 years or so I've
managed to keep doing just that at
Microsoft
Cortana um building out Alexa at Amazon
working on pytorch at meta and building
my own AI startup that was working on a
devops assistant now at data dog we're
building out bits AI which is the AI
assistant who's there to help all of you
with your devops
problems so today I'll little I'll talk
a little about that talk a little about
the history of AI at data dog a little
bit about how we think about AI agents
today and where we think things are
going for the
future day dog is the observability and
security platform for cloud applications
there's a lot that we do um um but it
kind of all boils down to being able to
observe what's happening in your system
and take action on that make it easier
to understand make it easier for us to
uh simply understand and build out
things to have a safer and more devops
friendly
system we've been shipping AI for quite
a while actually um it's not always
inyour face it's not always out there
saying here's a big AI product but
things like proactive alerting really
understanding things like r analysis
impact analysis and change tracking and
much more has been happening since 2015
or
so but things are changing this is a
clear era shift I think of this kind of
similar terms to the microprocessor or
the shift to SAS um bigger smarter
models reasoning and multimodal coming
uh Foundation model Wars happening this
General shift where intelligence becomes
too Shi too cheap to
meter and what this means is product
like cursor are growing you know
terribly fast um and really people are
expecting more and more from AI every
day um with these advancements at data
dog we're really trying to rise to meet
this shift as well the future is
uncertain this kind of ambiguity creates
opportunity but there's a lot of
potential for us that's kind of the
dawning of this intelligence age we're
working to move up the stack to leverage
these advancements and give even more to
our customers by making it so that you
don't use data dog as just just the
devop platform but also as AI agents
that use that platform for you this
requires work in a few key areas that
I'll talk about developing the actual
agents doing eval you just heard a lot
about eval we think about that every day
for better or worse um and building out
new types of
observability there's a few agents that
we're working on right now in private
beta the first is the AI software
engineer this kind of looks at problems
for you looks at errors tries to
recommend code uh that we can generate
to help you improve your system the
second is the AI on call engineer this
wakes up for you in the middle of the
night does your work hopefully makes it
so you have to get page less frequently
and then we have a lot more on the
way so I'm going to talk a little bit
about the AI on call engineer first this
is the one that you know everyone wants
to save them from that 2 am. alert you
don't want to have to wake up in the
middle of the night go and look through
your run book go and figure out what's
going on if you can help it our on call
engineer is there to really make it so
you can keep sleeping this agent
proactively kicks off when an alert
occurs and works to First situationally
Orient read things like your run books
grab context of the alert and then goes
and you know figures out the kind of
common stuff that each of you would do
on data dog already look through logs
look through metrics look through traces
and kind of act in this Loop to figure
out what's going
on the en call agent's great for both
automatically running investigations for
me but also you know being able to look
through and find summaries and find
information for me before I even get to
my computer so if I want to get insights
into why an alert just occurred or
figure out why a trace might uh be
showing an error this agent can jump
ahead pull information for me and show
it to me we also have added a new page
that makes it easy so that you can have
human AI collaboration this is still
something I'm thinking about a lot is
like what what kind of collaboration do
we expect we want our agents to act as
humans but we also need to be able to
verify what they did and be able to kind
of look over what they're doing and
really learn from
it it also helps you to kind of earn
trust along the way I can see the reason
why uh this hypothesis for example was
generated I can see what the agent found
and I can make decisions about whether
or not I agree along the
way it also tells you things like what
steps did it actually take out of your
runbook and kind of like a junior
engineer who does this work I can go ask
follow-up questions find out why I did a
certain thing
a little more insight into how we're
making this happen much like a human s
or devops engineer our agent Works to
put together hypothesis on what might be
happening and reason over them coming up
with ways to test them use tools in the
tool former sense to try out ideas run
queries against logs metrics Etc and
work to validate or invalidate each
hypothesis in the case that it does find
a solid root cause our agent cause uh
can suggest remediations along the way
again just like a human might might say
hey we should page in that other team
that's involved here or it might offer
to scale up or down your infrastructure
over time we plan to add more built-in
actions and eventually discover new
types of workflows based on what your
team has
done but if you already have certain
workflows that you set up in data dog um
we can tie directly into them and make
it so that our agent can understand
those workflows and how they might map
to helping you remediate a
problem and if it's a real incident the
enal engineer is not usually done once
an issue is remediated you usually go
and write a postmortem you go try to
learn from it you share it with your
team our agent can do the same write out
your postmortem for you look at what
occurred during the entire time what it
did what humans did and put that
together so that you have something
ready in the
morning so that was the en call engineer
um that's the one that is you know
trying to help you in the middle of the
night trying to help you every time
alerts come on um we also have this AI
software engineer I think of this as the
proactive developer the devops or
software engineering agent who observes
and acts on things like errors coming
through this is kind of the error
tracking assistant it automatically
analyzes these errors identifies causes
and proposes Solutions those Solutions
can include generating a code fix and
working to reduce the number of on call
incidents you have in the first place so
they can work in concer to make a better
system over time in this case the
assistant has caught a recursion issue
proposes a
fix and even creates a recursion test so
that we can catch it if it happens again
in the future we have the option to
create a PR in GitHub or open the diff
in vs code for editing this workflow
significantly reduces the time spent by
an engineer manually writing and testing
code and greatly reduces human time
spent
overall so what have we learned building
out these agents and some of the new
ones that we're working on today well
we've learned quite a lot um there's a
lot of things that we started with that
we kind of went back and and redid um
but a few areas I'll touch on that I
hope help you if you develop your own
first is scoping tasks for evaluation
it's very easy you know to build out
demos quickly much harder sometimes to
scope and eval what's occurring second
is building the right team who's ready
to move fast and deal with the ambiguity
that comes with these kind of problems
third is that you know the ux of old is
changing um that's something that
everyone needs to be comfortable with
and fourth is observability matters you
know uh I'm surprising for data do to
say that I'm sure but observability is
terribly important even in this new era
so scoping the problems scoping the work
to be done I like to think about this as
defining jobs to be done and really kind
of trying to clearly understand step by
step what you'd like to do think about
it from the human angle first and think
about how another human might go and
evaluate it um this is why we build out
vertical task specific agents rather
than building out generalized agents we
also want where possible this to be
measurable and verifiable and at each
step this has honestly been one of the
biggest pain points for for us and I
think this is true for many people
working in agents where you can quickly
build out a demo you can quickly build
something that looks like it works but
then it's very hard to actually verify
that over time and improve it um use
your domain experts but use them more
like design Partners or task verifiers
don't use them as the people who will go
and kind of write the code or rules for
it because there is a big difference in
how these kind of stochastic models work
versus how experts work you know
everyone kind of knows gnome and his uh
anti- NLP um rants but that kind of
stuff happens pretty frequently domain
experts eval eval eval I can't stress
this enough um start by thinking deeply
about your eval the number of mistakes
we made by not thinking about eval first
is uh frustrating and something that I
think everyone should think about it's
very easy to build these demos as I said
um but everything in this fuzzy
stochastic World requires good evil even
something small to start this means
offline online and kind of living Evo
have endtoend uh uh uh task have
endtoend measurements uh make it so you
also instrument appropriately the way to
know if humans are using your product
right and giving you feedback and then
make this a living breathing test
set building the team um you don't have
to have a bunch of ml experts there
aren't that many to go around right now
um what you really need is you want to
seat it with one or two and then have a
bunch of optimistic generalists who are
very good at writing code and very
willing to try things out fast um I'll
also note that ux in front end matters
more than I'd like as a backend engineer
myself um but it's terribly important as
you collaborate with these with these
agents and
assistants um and then you want
teammates and people who are excited to
be AI augmented themselves this is
day-to-day AI use this is Explorer types
who want to learn this is a field that's
changing fast um and if you don't have
people like that you're going to kind of
get
stuck you want folks who kind of you
know yeah yearn for the vast and endless
AI capabilities right um it's a big
world out there and there's a lot going
on Ye Old ux um this is one of those
things that I still you know we think
about we go back and forth every day um
it's an area that I didn't realize was
quite so important initially when I
started working in this field um despite
my engineering sensibilities and lack of
ux is terribly important um this is such
an early space of work this is kind of
one of the more important things here as
you collaborate and work together but
the old ux patterns are changing be
comfortable with that um and so far I'm
partial to agents that work more and
more like human teammates instead of
building out a bunch of new pages or
buttons so who watches the Watchmen
right um You have these agents running
around um observability is actually
really important and don't make it an
afterthought um these are complex
workflows you really need situational
awareness to debug problems and this has
saved us time a lot as we start to work
with um a new view that we're calling LM
observability in the data dog
product um Daya dog in general has a
full observability stack as many of you
know know we can look at gpus um we can
look at llm monitoring we can look at
really your system end to end but tying
in the llm observability has been very
helpful because you have a wide variety
of interactions and calls out to models
you're hosting models you're running
maybe models you're using through an API
and we can make them all uh kind of
group together in the same paint of
glass so you can look at them and debug
what's
occurring I will note though that this
can get messy fast with agents our agent
for example has very complex multi-step
calls you're not going to look at this
and figure out what's going on right
away Um this can be hundreds of calls
this can be uh you know uh tons of
different places where it's making
decisions about tools looping time and
time again and if you just look through
a full list of these things you'll never
really figure out what's going on so
here's a quick you know sneak peek into
a more agent view of what's occurring
inside of our observability tools this
is our agent graph um really what this
means is that I can kind of look at it
just like our agent did and looking at
workflows that are occurring you can see
in this even though it's a big graph uh
there's a bright red node here if we
zoom into that we can actually see where
errors were occurring this is very human
readable something that makes it super
easy to figure out what's going on when
your complex workflow is
running as an as side though I do also
want to note what I think of as kind of
like the agent or application layer
bitter lesson uh General methods that
can leverage new off the shelf models
are ultimately the most effective um by
a large margin um I hate to say it but
like you sit there you fine-tune you do
all this work on like the specific uh
you know project the specific task and
then all of a sudden you know open AI or
someone comes out with a new model and
it handles all this you know kind of
quickly a lot of the reasoning is solved
for you um we're not quite there where
it handles all of it very quickly but
you should be at a point where you can
easily try out any of these models um
and don't feel stuck to a particular
model that you're you've been working on
for a while you know Rising tide lifts
all boat here
um I also think a lot about not just
building agents but what it might mean
for other agents to be users of data dog
and other SAS products um there's a good
chance that agents surpass humans as
users in the next five years um I'm
probably somewhere in the middle on my
estimate there you know there are people
who will tell you that'll happen in the
next year the'll people who will tell
you you know it'll happen in 10 years I
think we're somewhere around the
fiveyear Mark um but this means that you
shouldn't just be building for humans or
building your own agents you should
really think about agents that might use
your product as well an example of the
is like third party agents like Claude
might use you know data dog directly I
set this up with mCP relatively quickly
um but any type of agent that might be
coming in and using your platform you
should think of the context you want to
provide them the information you want to
provide about your apis that agents
would use more than
humans so looking ahead um the future is
going to be weird it'll be fun uh and AI
accelerating is accelerating each and
every day I strongly believe that we'll
be able to offer a team of Dev SEC op
agents AG For Hire to each of you soon
you don't have to go and use our
platform directly and integrate directly
ideally our agents will do that for you
and our agents will handle your on call
and everything like that for you um I
also do think that AI agents will be
customers many of you building out SRE
agents and other types of Agents coding
agents should use our platform should
use our tools um just like a human would
and uh we can't wait to see
that and generally I think that small
companies out there are going to be
building built by someone who can use
autom developers like cursor or Devon to
get their ideas out into the real world
and then agents like ours to handle
operations and Security in a way that
lets you know in order of magnitude more
ideas make it out into the real
world thank you so much um please reach
out if you're building any agents that
want to use us um or if you'd like to
check out our agents as well um there's
a lot to build here and if you want to
work in the space we are hiring more AI
engineers and people who are just
excited about it but thank you very much
[Music]